hundreds of corporate lobbyists write a
trade deal that no one reads will it
still affect you yeah the trans-pacific
partnership is the largest trade deal in
US history covering 40 percent of the
global economy it'll increase exports
between 12 countries and impact jobs
food the environment and more President
Obama says it's good for everyone but
why are he and other leaders keeping it
under lock and key four chapters were
leaked and here's what the critics say
would happen if it passes corporations
will be able to sue countries in secret
tribunals for making laws that cut into
their projected profits like a cigarette
company suing a country over packaging
it'll give Big Pharma a monopoly on drug
patents which will drive up the cost of
drugs that treat illnesses like cancer
and malaria and the TPP also undermines
internet freedoms it forces service
providers to police the net by cracking
down on things like illegal downloads so
is this really a trade deal or a Trojan
horse for multinational corporations